Mathieu pilote fait le tour de sa
maternité pour s'assurer que ces truies
et leur porcelets se portent bien mais
ces jours-ci il a d'autres
préoccupations en tête le couteau autour
de la gorge
depuis le printemps dernier les
producteurs de port doivent consentir un
rabais à l'e-mail et aux autres
transformateurs alors que les prix du
port ont fluctué entre 200 et 320
dollars pour 100 kg une escompte de 40
dollars a d'abord été exigé puis elle a
été abaissée à 25 dollars démontant qui
nuisent la rentabilité des porcheries à
toutes les fois j'ai envoyé un cochon à
Labattoir et je perds 50 dollars soit on
leur donnait le rabais soit il prenait
plus cochon puis fermer
on n'avait pas le choix le fallait faire
ça pour sauver l'industrie l'industrie
et secouée par une crise qui découle en
grande partie des difficultés
financières de l'e-mail qui possède
quatre abattoirs de port au Québec un
email est un joueur majeur dans le
marché donc lorsque ce joueur là est en
difficulté mais c'est toute la filière
là qui est qui est en difficulté au
cours des dernières années l'entreprise
a subi les contrecoups de la fermeture
du marché chinois aux exportations
canadiennes de port et de longs conflit
de travail à son usine de valéronction
c'est sans compter la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qui limite les possibilités
d'effectuer des coupes à valeur ajoutée
qui sont plus payantes pour l'entreprise
le taux d'utilisation d'un abattoir est
extrêmement important pour sa
profitabilité si je n'ai pas
suffisamment employé mon taux
d'utilisation de mon abattoir diminue et
ça affecte directement ma profitabilité
alors tout ça s'accumule l'acquisition
importante un endettement plus important
une tempête parfaite a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue dans le cadre de
ce reportage puisque l'entreprise et les
autres transformateurs de port sont en
train de négocier une nouvelle
convention de mise en marché avec les
producteurs l'ancien ministre des
Finances Raymond Bachant a été nommé
conciliateur dans ce dossier la
Fédération des éleveurs espèrent un
dénouement rapide nous ce qu'on veut
savoir une un partenariat d'affaires qui
est durable à long terme lorsque des
demandes sont faits à court terme nous
en tant que producteur on peut pas sur
virer sur une scène c'est pas c'est pas
un interrupteur qu'on a dans nos
entreprises puis qu'on arrête puis qu'on
recommence on sait déjà que ce sera pas
la convention qu'on avait
ça va être moins bon les producteurs
peuvent compter sur l'assurance
stabilisation pour compenser une partie
de leur perte en 2022 ils ont reçu près
de 200 millions de dollars cette
assurance est financée aux deux tiers
par le gouvernement donc les
contribuables et autres tiers par les
éleveurs indirectement les producteurs a
fait et la société québécoise est en
train de subventionner
prochaine faites là à un moment donné
vient un thème ce que c'est que c'est
plus vierge selon Matthieu pilote le
gouvernement devrait soutenir les
producteurs encore davantage il fait
valoir que l'industrie génère 31 000
emplois dans la province et des
retombées de plus de 3 milliards de
dollars par année qui proviennent en
grande partie des exportations un point
9 milliards d'exportation d'argent neuf
qui rendent au Québec
trouvez-moi un investissement sur
rentable que ça pour le gouvernement
sûrement
l'inquiétude grimpe et certains songes a
quitté l'industrie j'ai des téléphones
de producteurs qui me demandent ou qui
me disent qu'ils vont quitter la
production j'en connais personnellement
qui ont arrêté
si la 2023 ça en ligne pour pas être
rentable encore à cause qu'il faut
donner encore un rabais un moment donné
on voit la tuer l'industrie possible
la filière du port est à la croisée des
chemins